tí chỉnh xem tiếng tiếng B Tí luôn Alo ạ
Alo nghe các bạn nghe thấy không ạ Alo
alo alo
bảo Thì lúc đầu ấ sẽ kiểu COD trước đã
sau đó thì kiểu mình sẽ COD tầm tiếng
sau đó thì mình mới tâm sự Thực ra là
cũng Hình như là cũng phải gần hai tuần
rồi đúng không lần cuối Tôi livestream
gần hai tuần trước tuần trước thì à Để
tôi nhớ lại lý
do trước nhìn nà đầu tiên thì à đúng R
mình nhớ là tuần trước là mình à cũng ốm
thì phải ốm sau đó thì có
việc xong rồi hôm trước trước thì là
lạnh
nữa quá lạnh để làm gì đó ô hôm thứ ba
vừa rồi quá lạnh kiểu không không ra nổi
khỏi dường kiểu cũng khá là mệt kiểu là
bởi vì tính ra là công việc của tôi đến
bây giờ vẫn gọi
nhở Nói thoải mái thì cũng đúng Nhưng mà
nói căng kiểu căng ấy thì cũng đúng bởi
vì ví dụ vừa rồi nhá Tôi 6:30 tôi mới
bắt đầu về đấy Kiểu thế tức là mang
tiếng là bọn tôi chuẩn là ừ Tức là chuẩn
cũng về par từ 6:30 nhỉ Ờ nhưng mọi khi
tôi toàn kiểu Bọn tôi có thể thoải mái
kiểu linh hoạt linh hoạt giờ đến và giờ
về mà Tất cả cũng chỉ là 6 gi cũng có
thể về nếu mà tạm Xuôi xuôi việc rồi
nhưng mà 6:30 vừa rồi Kiểu anh em giục
về vì anh em kiểu cũng nhớ nhà và đói
các thứ chứ không phải công việc xong
nhá Đấy thì chị mấy ông biết được công
việc căng nha Thì hôm nay để để gọi như
là Ừ để bù đắp được cho các bạn về mấy
tuần không Mấy buổi không livestream thì
hôm nay không phải ngồi code về mỗi đồ
án nữa mà tôi xin phép kiểu chia sẻ về
những cái khác
em mới học par end và còn khá lơ mơ về
đánh Index anh có thể V ví dụ về part H
index được không ạ
Ồ em hỏi hai cái đến chính anh cũng lơ
mơ về nó
ờ nên là anh anh nghĩ là chính anh còn
lơ mơ về nó mà mang tiế anh rất là để mà
nói thì anh rất là thích về
database cái b end Thực ra nó rất là à
back back and Ừ đấy một trong những cái
tôi thường th phát âm sai nữa back and Ờ
tôi vẫn cay cái quả Tại sao tôi gọi là
backend hay vì backend vì cái nhóm nhạc
tôi thích có bài hát kểu x có câu nó là
B Kiss Boy it B à như Thực ra nó là back
back end Ừ ừ đại khái là back end nó có
rất là rộng Nếu mà em nói mới học với
bác back end thì thực ra là có rất nhiều
thứ em cần phải học là không còn về cái
kia thì thực ra nó khá là chuyên sâu về
database và về sau đương nhiên em muốn
biết vẫn được nhưng mà anh nghĩ là ừ
chưa đến lúc phải biết sẽ có rất rất
nhiều thứ mà mình cần phải về sau mình
gọi là từng bước từng bước ấy chứ việc
là bây giờ mình biết thực ra nó cũng
chẳng sao cả nhưng mà
À mình sẽ dễ bị quá tải vì tính ra thì
học lập trình này ví dụ đến thời điểm
hiện tại mang tiếng là tôi tôi
kiểu làm và học khá là lâu rồi
tôi tôi nghĩ thế Nhưng mà vẫn Đư nhiên
là vẫn cảm thấy là mình vẫn kiến thức
của mình biết có khi là chỉ 1 ph thì có
khi là nhiều đấy thì mấy ông mới biết
được là nó có thể rộng như thế nào nhưng
mà hoàn toàn là vẫn khẳng định là mình
vẫn làm được việc với toàn bộ kiến thức
mình đang biết Còn khi gọi giống như là
sếp tôi đướng đ nói đó là đỗi Khi thực
sự là mình đánh mình đừng có nghĩ quá
nhiều mình đừng coi mọi thứ quá quan
trọng đợi đến khi đúng thời điểm thì
mình mới cần biết đấy Kiểu như thế đừng
có nên biết quá nhiều quá được ra nó chỉ
làm mình loạn đầu và suy nghĩ quá nhiều
thôi nếu mà nó thực sự quan trọng Hồi
Trích lời của Sếp tôi nhá Nếu nó thực sự
quan trọng thì bạn đã nhớ bạn sẽ không
quên nó đâu đấy còn một khi mà bạn đã
quên nó ví dụ Giả sử bạn đang nghĩ là
bạn đang chuẩn bị làm gì đó tự nhiên bạn
quên r Bạn cố ngồi nhớ lại việc là kiểu
đấy cố nhớ lại nói thì có khi thực ra nó
không quan trọng như thế đâu nghĩa có
thật sự có khi nó không quan trọng đáng
thì bạn phải làm thế chứ khi bạn chỉ nhớ
bọ không tốt thật chứ Một khi là nó quan
trọng thì kiểu gì bạn sẽ nhớ lại nó thôi
và cái này cũng thế Có nhiều cái ặn
tưởng là lúc này nó quan trọng nhưng
thực ra có khi là bạn không bao giờ kiểu
đấy Bây giờ giả sử tôi còn chưa biết mấy
cái kia nhưng tôi bản thân tôi không B
giờ động vào nó nên là tôi cảm thấy là
có thể tôi sẽ không cần phải biết nó
đúng không đấy thì có những cái mà giả
sử là nếu nó thực sự quan trọng thực sự
cần thì về sau bạn kiểu gì bạn cũng sẽ
biết đấy còn nếu mà nó
đấy thì ngược lại nếu mà nó không quan
trọng thì việc gì mình phải biết tại
thời điểm hiện tại đúng không mình bản
thân là lập trình nó có rất nhiều thứ
cần phải biết và cần phải làm nhưng mà
cái thứ cần biết ấy code là để làm được
mà đúng không ạ Thế rõ ràng là bạn vẫn
đang đủ kiến thức để bạn làm được thì
bạn cứ làm thôi đã đợi khi nào mà khi
nào mà có vấn đề xảy ra Ví dụ ví dụ Giả
sử nhá Tại sao tự nhiên tôi đam mê về
database như thế bởi vì à Kiểu về sau nó
phát sinh rất nhiều bài toán nghiệp vụ
là kiểu Tôi thấy truy vấn tôi càng càng
nặng hơn đấy Xong rồi phải xử lý dữ liệu
đến hàng triệu bản ghi đến đến hàng trăm
triệu bản ghi nên là cái câu chuy vấn
rất là nặng nên thành ra là mình nghĩ
việc nên tối về database đấy Đấy là một
cách thôi nhá Đấy
thì thì lúc đấy mới động vào còn bây giờ
bản thân là rất nhiều lúc rất nhiều lúc
tôi đang ngồi code tôi vẫn ngồi nghĩ
việc tối ưu à code đoạn này sao cho kiểu
về sau dễ sửa hay về sau kiểu tối ưu cho
về sau chạy nhanh Xong rồi Sếp tôi toàn
nói kiểu đừng có nghĩ cao siêu Thế em ạ
Chắc gì về sau còn đúng nghiệp vụ này để
mà để mà làm như thế nhớ đâu về sau đập
đi làm lại theo nghiệm vụ khác thì sao
đấy hoặc là thậm chí là về sau nói hơi
nói hơi kiểu hơi vô trách nhiệm một tí
nhưng mà về sau nhớ đâu người người phải
sửa đạn đấy không phải là em thì
sao đấy nếu mà Đúng là suy nghĩ thế hơi
vô trách nhiệm thật mình vẫn code sao
cho mà người sau C hiểu được cái đoạn
mình code để họ còn dám vào sửa hoặc ít
nhất ít nhất giống như là tôi đang làm
đó là có thể code mình à Không biết được
code mình khó hiểu hay dễ hiểu theo tùy
từng người cảm nhận nhưng mà vẫn phải
viết test viết mọi thứ ôm cho cái tính
năng đấy chạy được và đảm bảo nó vẫn
đang chạy đúng chạy được để về sau người
nào mà có lỡ sự sửa vào đoạn đấy người
ta chạy lại test của mình mà nó vẫn đấy
nó vẫn pass nó vẫn thành công thì chứng
tỏ là họ vẫn đang sửa đúng vẫn đúng
nghiệp vụ thế là được đúng không ạ
ôi mang tiếng là bảo là ngồi codt xong
rồi cũng gì ngồi tâm sự thêm một tí rồi
ok Bảo phỏng vấn hay bị hỏi thế á Anh
chưa giờ được hỏi thế
Ờ
anh anh thấy rất nhiều rất nhiều người
cố học cái gì đó để phỏng vấn thức ra
cái đấy để chuẩn bị nó tốt thì cũng tốt
thôi nhưng mà cá nhân anh ở góc độ ở đó
thì anh luôn thể hiện mình là người làm
được việc chứ không phải người chỉ trả
lời được qua cái phòng vào phần phòng
phòng vấn bởi vì Ừ anh còn Thậm chí
không đánh giá cao những cái nơi mà
phỏng vấn những cái câu mà kiểu gọi là
kiến thức nó hơi bị mơ hồ thế kiểu nó
không thực tế thực tế mình chẳng bao giờ
làm vào tự nhiên nó n nào giống như là
bây giờ Hỏi hỏi tôi câu là kiểu có bao
nhiêu thẻ
HTML kiểu chịu luôn ấy Kiểu mình quan
tâm với cái điều đấy làm gì đúng không ạ
Đấy đấy là một trong thôi Tôi vẫn nhớ
hồi trước có một người thầy tôi biết có
dạy đầy đủ tất cả các thẻ HTML ở trên w3
school có rất nhiều cái thẻ mà kểu Lần
Đầu Lần Đầu Tôi thấy trong đời luôn đấy
nghĩ chỉ
Mình mà biết mấy cái kiến thức đấy nó
hơi thừa với cá nhân tôi là nó sẽ thừa
vì những có rất nhiều cái là ông tra
Google được mà ông không cần nhớ những
cái mà ông có thể tra được Ông chỉ c
biết từ khóa hoặc là Ừ biết được nó có
tồn tại thôi còn việc về kiểu nó không
áp dụng thường xuyên ý những cái gì
không áp dụng thường xuyên thì mình
chẳng cần gì phải nhớ cả đúng không
ạ Em đang học về fql đang thắc mắc về
chỗ group by anh có thể chị em em biết
group 3 được không
thân mình chẳng biết group 3 là cái gì
cả Hôm nay mình vừa mới chợt nhớ nhớ đến
cái thời đấy của mình hôm nay vừa
xong mình cảm thấy là Ui bây giờ đúng là
mình cũng rất là xịn rồi Khi mà toàn
mình biết cách truy vấn vừa tối ưu vừa
lấy ra được những cái thứ mình cần lấy
rồi và mình xử lý mang tiếu mình không
biết về thật toán nhưng mình biết xử lý
dữ liệu các thứ làm việc với mảng rất là
nhiều chiều để lấy dữ liệu ra rồi rồi
mình mới nhận thấy là mấy cái câu truy
vấn Hồi trước mình làm phức tạp vãi
chưởng không cần phải làm đ to bu lớn
như thế
đấy Cái Hồi đấy tôi cũng rất là đau đầu
với group bu xong rồi join xong rồi vân
vân nên là tôi nghĩ là ông làm đủ lâu và
rất nhiều bài toán toán nghiệp vụ phức
tạp thì tự Ông vẫn lẽ ra thôi Còn bây
giờ thời gian đầu thì chắc là làm một
vài bài tập nhỏ kiểu gr b k Sam sụ các
thứ và chấp nhận là ừ nó ra kết quả được
là được chứ còn về sau để
mà để mà thực sự là tối yêu các thứ thứ
thì phải chảy nhiều đấy không phải có
một sự thật là không phải ai cũng chuyên
về SQL đến chính bản thân tôi vừa phải
đây tôi hôm qua tôi vừa phải dạy cho cho
anh Sếp của tôi Sếp của tôi nhá về mấy
cái cơ bản đối với tôi nó cơ bản này mà
rất nhiều anh em không anh em mang tiế
lập trình cò còn bỡ ngỡ
Ờ em
upl 20 cái CV đi thực tập chưa được r
cái này thì thực ra thì do ai cũng thế
với thời này cạnh tranh Tôi không biết
là tôi có
thể chia sẻ cho các bạn kiểu gì vì theo
tôi tôi chưa được trải nghiệm kiểu này
thì tính ra tôi vẫn may may là vẫn được
mời về chứ không đi phỏng vấn đi apply
cái gì bao giờ cả nhưng
mà nhưng mà theo tôi thì thời gian này
không phải là bây giờ ông nên apply
nhiều hơn nó n áo giống tôi tôi từng So
sánh các bạn rồi nó n áo giống việc là
Ừ cái việc đăng ký nộp vào công ty nào
các thứ giống như việc ông đi tán gái
dạo
vậy một là ông xác định tìm hiểu đúng
một đối tượng và ông theo đuổi đúng một
người và ông sẽ cố gắng kiểu để cho nó
xứng đôi vừa lướng người ra cố gắng hết
mình để cạnh tranh các thứ thứ chứ chứ
không nên là kiểu dạng ông đi ngồi thả
thính
nm đợi một em nào đó chấp nhận thì lúc
đấy Cái em chấp nhận mình cũng có thể là
không ổn gì đó vì bản thân mình cũng
đang Đang ổn đâu đấy Nói chung là mình
phải đang thực sự ổn thì một là người ta
sẽ tìm đến theo kiểu là cũng bắt kịp
sóng và bắt cùng Trung tần số vân vân
đấy theo tôi là như thế nghĩa trong thời
gian này ông nên hoàn thiện bản thân như
kiểu làm thêm dự án
Ờ làm thêm theo mấy cái pet Project theo
sở thích cá nhân để và có cái thứ để
khoe khi phỏng vấn Chứ bây giờ một khi
người ta mời ông đi phỏng vấn mà ông chỉ
có mỗi cái cv kiến thức của ông vẫn chỉ
là kiến thức cơ bản trên trường thì ông
khó khó có cửa nhiều nhiều lắm bởi vì
anh em ngoài kia đa số vẫn thấy giống
hệt Thế
chy vấn những thông tin thì khi cho hai
hoặc nhiều bạc thì group by theo những
cái muốn chy vấn thì có đúng không ạ
Không em múp B bản chân bản thân nó sinh
ra để để khi một khi mà em sử dụng những
cái liên quan đến kiểu hing này XM này
mấy cái kiểu dạng là liên quan nhóm lại
để tính toán
ấy kiểu min max này các thứ thì em mới
nên dùng group buy hoặc để lọc một phần
là để lọc ví dụ là em muốn lấy ra tất cả
ID cho nhiều bảng thì em muốn
lấy mấy cái kiểu trùm nhau thì em có thể
dùng group by hoặc là distin cũng được
đấy Nói chung là cái này anh nghĩ vẫn
phải trả nhiều anh không biết được mô tả
nào cụ thể
không có chỗ thực tập thì trường đánh
trợt môn anh ạ Ừ Thực ra là các bạn vẫn
đang quan tâm về việc là Ừ thì đúng là
nó bị gánh nặng về cả trường áp lực
nhưng mà trường áp lực một phần thôi Anh
nghĩa là bản thân mình tự tạo lực mình
thôi mình đừng quan tâm với việc trường
đánh trượt hay cái gì đó cả
mà công việc này nếu mà em xác định theo
nganh này lâu dài thì em thực sự là kiểu
quan tâm nó việc là mình muốn khởi đầu
mọi thứ Lợi ổn vân vân vân gắn bón lâu
dài chứ đâu phải quan tâm về mỗi môn học
tôi Thực ra tôi hồi đi học tôi không
quan tâm điểm số hay kiểu cá th sứ thế
đâu bằng cấp với tôi tôi còn cảm thấy
Trọng quận trọng nó chỉ cái thứ chứng
minh là mình nh mình có học thôi có được
đào tạo thôi chứ thực ra là mình vẫn gọi
là đi làm thì vẫn thể hiện đúng năng lực
mình ch đâu liên quan bằng cấp hay là
điểm đúng không
Ok Bây giờ tôi sẽ thử chỉ â mấy ông về
cái này có ai ở đây biết về à Chắc là
mấy ông tôi bảo đôi khi mấy ông cũng
toàn Junior cả nên có không biết ở đây
có ai xio không thể biết về mấy cái này
như là xio chắc không Thời gian ngồi
nghe tôi chém gió đâu nhưng
mà ai ở đây biết về Union Joy
wiin Tôi muốn so sánh ở đây nó sẽ có
những cái này này join này We In này và
join sub này hôm đấy Thực ra tôi có cái
đề bài như này để tôi thử cho mấy ông
xem cái đềbài
với cái đề bài
rồi
bảng này bảng product option này
Ờ Giả sử là tôi có một cái
option là màu sắc và kích thước đúng
không ạ Đây cái ba là màu sắc đúng không
ạ Đây cái ba này cái ba này đúng không ạ
thế giờ giả sử Giả sử là hôm nấy tôi làm
cái tính năng Đó là đề xuất ra sản phẩm
tương tự để mà gọi là khái niệm bên tôi
bán hàng gọi upsale tức là kiểu dạng là
là gợi ý những sản phẩm bán kèm ấy để mà
để mà kiểu nó gợi ý giống như kiểu bên
ông hay đặt ở mấy trang thê mại điện tử
kiểu dạng là
à Ông mua cái cái laptop thì nó sẽ đề
xuất thêm cái con chuột chẳng hạn hoặc
cái ban phím chẳng hạn đúng không ạ thì
tức là nó sẽ hoặc là chỉ đơn giản là cái
laptop thì nó ông mua một con laptop thì
nó sẽ đề xuất những con laptop kiểu nó
cũng cấu hình tương đương chẳng hạn thế
đấy thì cái đấy khái niệm là upsale tức
là gợi ý những sản phẩm có thể bán cùng
đấy
thì thì hôm đấy tôi làm cái câu truy vấn
Đó là kiểu ví dụ là đây mấy ông thấy là
có cùng là option 3 đây Tôi cho ông xem
cùng option 3 Ông mấy ông thấy là có
product ID là 2 và 3 tức là chị là là cả
hai cái product này đều có cùng cái
option này đúng không ạ Thế bây giờ mình
bây giờ Giả sử có bài toán là bây giờ
mấy ông truy vấn sao cho bây giờ mấy ông
viết câu SQL kiểu gì để mà để mà kiểu
lấy ra tất cả sản phẩm Tất cả sản phẩm
có trùng với trùng cái tất cả option
đây mấy ông thấy là có product id2
product ID 3 đúng không Bây giờ mình
muốn lấy tất cả sản phẩm có chùng tất cả
option của thằng product ID là 2 m có
nghe kỹ đề bài không ạ gi viết thử đề
mày không xem
product có cùng option
với
product ID bằng 2 chẳng hạn
hiểu đề bài không
ạ m ông có thể không không biết cách làm
nhưng mấy ông cứ nói với tôi rồi mấy ông
hiểu đi nhá Thế có gì tôi gửi ý cách làm
nh Mấy ông không hiểu đề bài nữa thì tôi
không biết được không biết nên nh như
hiểu một đề bài mà đúng không Cứ cho
hiểu nha
Ờ nhưng đương nhiên là bây giờ để Bởi vì
bây giờ đang có mỗi sản phẩm Hai và sản
phẩm 3 thì bây giờ để tôi sẽ thêm
a một cái option mới đi cái là
đây
là option sai đi sai đây chỉ sai ấ nghĩa
là kiểu không hợp lệ đây không hợp lệ
lệ kiểu như
không không phải save sao đâu bây
giờ cùng option cơ Nghĩa là nghĩa là bản
chất là em phải lấy tất cả các option
của product ID bằng 2 đã xong rồi We In
trong cái danh sách đấy đấy một cách
tôi mới làm thì mấy ông sẽ dễ hình dung
hơn đây có product 4 nhá Giả sử Tôi có
cái 4 này với option là 5 này Đấy ABC
đây không hợp lệ đúng không Thế giờ thế
giờ rõ ràng là thằng 3 này thằng 3 này
có trù trùng 3 và 4 luôn với thằng 2
đúng không Đấy Tôi sẽ tạo thêm một cái
nữa là tháng n này có chung cái thằng ba
thôi đây không hợp lệ
nha
đấy thì thì bây giờ tôi muốn lấy
chỉ h hai cực hai cực Thế hai cực
đấy rõ ràng mấy ông hiểu hiểu cái đề bài
chưa Đã Nghĩa là nghĩa là giả sử là sản
phẩm hai này của tôi có option là kích
màu sắc và kích thước đây tôi truy vấn
thẳng cho mấy ông dễ hình dung đấy cứ
phải truy vânn
đã form Này
ID bằng
product ch ID bằng 2 đây mình lấy name
ra sau đó thì mình join thêm
option đấy gợi ý nào Đúng rồi quá đỉ rồi
tiếp với option
đây có cái là
product ch name và
option chn
Ok đó mấy ông thấy là cái product
product ID 2 này này nó có như này đấy
tôi thêm cái product
option chấm value nữa thì mấy ông sẽ dễ
hình dung hơn đấy nó cái cái áo tool này
này đúng không đấy tôi làm cái vụ
reformat của thằng PSP Storm m Ông thấy
xịn không ạ đấy trông kiểu reformat lại
trông xịn này truy vấn gợi ý ra đàng
hoàng Đẹp như này đấy m Ông còn cứ ngồi
Khoe với tôi vs code thì sao có tuổi như
này
Ờ đấy Ờ gì
nhỉ Mấy ông hiểu đoạn này không ạ Tôi có
cái áo thun nhá Có Ừ có có những cái
option là màu sắc và kích thước
không không quan tâm về cái giá trị của
nó nhá Nhưng mà hiểu được là nó sẽ có
màu sắc và kích thước đúng không ạ thì
bây giờ bây giờ không không quan tâm về
giá trị nhá Bây giờ tôi cần lấy là tất
cả những cái thằng product có cùng màu
có có option là màu sắc và có hoặc là
option về kích thước hoặc là nhá hoặc là
trước đã nhá Còn mình muốn làm tối ưu
theo kiểu là bắt buộc phải có cả hai
cũng được đấy Nói chung là bài toán ở
đây nó như thế thì tôi sẽ hướng dẫn mấy
ông cách truy vấn các thứ thứ Ôi cái này
Ôi thôi Tôi không nghĩ là là ai ở ngoài
kia dạy cho mấy ông đâu Hồi mà tôi đi
học tôi có được dạy đâu và cái này nó
nâng cao đấy nhá Cái này rất là nâng cao
Tôi vẫn nhớ bài học xương máu cái hồi
tôi kể mấy ông chưa nhỉ cái hồi đầu tiên
tôi đi thực tập không phải công ty này
nhá công ty trước trước Cái khồi đấy là
tôi thực tập năm năm HA xong tôi đi làm
thực tập nửa năm ở một công ty như tôi
từ kể mấy ông về vụ đấy rồi đó là kiểu
nói chung là mình còn đang rất là non và
xanh đấy Xong rồi lúc mà làm đến một
thời gian Tôi truy vấn thì đương nhiên
là chỉ truy vấn những cái cơ bản kiểu
selec sao xong rồi Kiểu group by mức
tươc đối vân vân nên là xong có những
bảng gì nó Joi hết vào mới thử thử đấy
Xong rồi anh đấy từng nói một câu đó là
không ai dạy em về Q à À đấy Ui tôi nhớ
quả đấy quả cay vậy chưởng lúc đấy kì
mình cũng biết được là mình yếu như thế
nào nhưng mà nhưng mà kiểu không ai cứu
mình lúc đấy ông hiểu không không dạy
kiến thức trên trường thì cũng chỉ kiểu
mấy cái cơ bản thôi đúng
không Bây giờ ấy ra còn có hacker rank
hồi đây tôi chẳng biết hacker rank là
cái gì cả mà hacker Anh có khi là nó
cũng không nói cái bài toán kiểu thực tế
như này có thể có đấy tôi Thực ra tôi
vẫn chưa làm hết Nhưng mà mấy lần cái
lần cuối Tôi tôi thử mấy cái câu truy
vấn trên đấy ấy nó cũng khó đấy nhưng mà
nó cứ không thực tế Không biết được mấy
bài sau thế nào như tôi bỏ cái đoạn mà
nó kiểu ngồi kiểm tra vĩ độ
à Tôi cảm thấy là nó vẫn chưa đủ để cho
khiến cho mình có những cái bài toán
thực thực tế như này đấy tôi thử ra đề
bài mấy ông thực tế như này đây
à xem mấy ông xio nào làm được Tôi ra đề
bài này ở trên chữ trên công ty tôi đấy
có ông nào ngồi làm được đâu Làm theo
kiểu dạng như này Đây đây là hướng hướng
cách làm của mấy anh em trên công ty nhá
đây có cùng option như này các thứ các
thứ đúng không ạ thì ở đây rõ ràng là
mấy ông thấy là có bảng thực ra nó cũng
chỉ liên quan Mỗi bảng product option
thôi đấy để mình lấy được ID mà đúng
không
Thì cách cách làm của mấy An em trên
công ty đó là lấy ra toàn bộ option ID
của product ID bằng 2 đó sau đó thì
à Lấy ra toàn bộ product
ID à
quin trong danh
sách option ID ở trên đấy Đấy cách làm
công ty của anh em trên công ty đa số
thực ra nó khá là dễ thế này Thực ra khá
là dễ truy vấn và cũng khá là dễ hiểu
đấy tôi thử cho mấy ông xem thì mấy ông
hình dung hơn
nhá ví dụ giả sử như này thì mấy ông
thấy ở đây nó sẽ có option ID
như mấy ông thấy là thằng product
product ID bằng 2 nó sẽ có option ID là
3 hoặc 4 Thế là mình chỉ cần truy vấn
vào trong chính cái bảng product option
này để lấy ra 34 thế thôi Cho xem
select
a from product option
đấy đấy ng product ID 2 mình sẽ lấy
option ID đó thì sẽ lấy ra được 3 và 4
đúng không ạ Đây là lấy tất cả các
option của thằng product ID này đúng
không Đấy đấy làm xong bước một rồi đúng
không Đấy Bước 1 còn bước hai thì chỉ
đơn giản là lấy ra toàn bộ product ID
đúng không rất là đơn giản mình sẽ
là select product
tạo ẩn cái này đi ạ from product
ID
đấy
sách này đó mình sẽ vứt cái đoạn
ng hôm trước tôi sửa Ừ cái reformat này
thự ra trông như l không đẹp qu lắm
thông
cả đó đấy sẽ lấy ra tất cả các product
ID này ông nào vừa nãy bảo là muốn muốn
dùng group by cũng cả lọp trùng đúng
không Thì giờ ông hoàn toàn có thể group
bu để mà lọp trùng hoặ ông distance như
này distance này đây sản phẩm 2 3 n Thực
ra là mình muốn loại bỏ thằng hai đi
cũng được nghĩa là en đấy Ui nó gây ý
chuẩn luôn này Đấy bởi vì bản chất là
bản chất là mình lấy luôn lại cái thằng
product cũ làm gì đúng không
ạ cho mọi người cho em hỏi Hiện anh đang
dạy về cái gì nhỉ về SQL em ạ truy vânn
SQL
Ờ đấy đây một cách theo trong trường hợp
này thì tôi khuyên nên dùng distance
bởi vì
à Chỉ có một cột Nếu giả sử các bạn muốn
lấy ra nhiều cột thì các bạn mới không
dùng distance mới dùng group bu group
buy product ID như th này cũng cũng sẽ
tương đương đấy còn không nó sẽ ra lặp
lại như này lặp lại thực ra không
thì các bạn truy vấn bằng l larel thì We
In trong cái danh sách này không sao Bây
giờ tôi thử Bây giờ tôi thử viết lại cái
này bằng code
MQL nhưng mà cậu truy vấn cái câu này
thì nó là SQL Nói chung rồi nên là thực
ra các bạn dùng mssql hay là PR thì câu
truy Vân nó cũng giống hệt nhau và và
gọi là như nào và gọi như nào Dung từ nh
cách thức của nó giống nhau à cách hoạt
động của nó giống nhau vân vân nghĩa là
kiến thức này hoàn toàn áp dụng cho hết
Ờ cái này để viết sang code p nhá thì
mình sẽ để tôi mở cái file tôi tạo file
test V chưa nhỉ Ừ tôi chưa có file test
Bây giờ tôi sẽ tạo một cái thường Hồi
trước tôi vẫn làm đó là tôi sẽ có một
cái
router ở đây gọi router
tí tôi nghĩ tôi sẽ dùng cái này
tôi sẽ dùng một cái như
đợi tì quên mất cách viết của cái kia cơ
hay như này
controller
đẩy code lên tí tôi phải đẩy code Lên CH
chuẩn chúng ta sẽ phải luôn đẩy code lên
theo từng ngày này kể cả mình đang dở
việcc để tránh việc mất
code mấy lầm trước code mà không bị đẩy
code lên thế lỗi tôi T controller
này Ừ không có name gì
đâu
đó này t sẽ demo cho mấy ông bây giờ
viết code viết code này Đầu tiên thì bây
giờ để lấy ra toàn bộ như mà Mấy ông
đang làm mấy ông đang thấy đấy Đây là
một câu truy vấn nhá À quên quên quên
tôi dạy kiểu truy vấn trước đã cho mấy
ông xem
không nên rồi về dis sao nó sẽ lọc trùng
tất cả các cột chứ không phải
Ờ Chứ không phải là cái distance cái cột
mà mong muốn nên là th ra đừng có nên
distance kiểu
đấy distance thì đương nhiên độc lập với
group by rồi em thể chọn một trong ha
À quên mất tôi phải chỉ cho mấy ông về
cái câu lệnh các thứ thứ đã thì mấy ông
thì khi mà viết code cho mấy ông mấy ông
dễ hình dung được ok Oki tạm chưa viết
code cho mấy ông vội đây mấy ông thấy là
đây là một cách nhá Đây là dùng qu in qu
in để lấy dữ liệu ra thế gi Tôi sẽ dạy
mấy ông về join và join sub nó như th
nào ở đây thứ nhất về nói về cái We In
trước đã nhá We In như th này nếu mà Mấy
ông viết như này này thì theo như tôi
nhớ Tôi nhớ thôi Tôi không tôi thưởng ng
chắc chắn nó nhưng mà nhưng mà biết đâu
bây giờ thay đổi rồi rồi hoặc là hoặc là
kiến thức của mình nó không chưa đủ
chuyên sâu như thế như theo tô nhớ bản
chất là cái cái này được tính là
subquery tức là sao là cứ nó cứ duyệt
Bạn ghi lần lượt lần lượt ví dụ Giả sử
đây bảng product option nhá Đây bảng
product option nó sẽ kiểm tra nó duyệt
từng bản ghi một này nó duyệt đến bản nó
con trỏ của nó sẽ trỏ đến đây đầu tiên
trỏ lần lượt lần lượt để nó kiểm tra xem
cái nào phù hợp phù hợp hay không ấy
Đúng rồi Mình dùng pp stom
Ờ nó nó duyệt nó trỏ đầu tiên nó trỏ đến
cái bản ghi đầu tiên này xong rồi nó
kiểm tra xem cái câu que của ông thỏa
mãn điều kiện hay
chưa giả sử là trong trường hợp này
là trong trường hợp này là chưa thỏa mãn
thì nó bắt đầu nhảy sang con trò lại
nhảy sang bạn kí tiếp theo s quay lại
kiểm tra cái câu que không thỏa mãn điều
kiện Chưa Cứ thế cứ thế thế nó sẽ duyệt
từng cái bản B ghi từng bản ghi từng bản
ghi từng bản ghi một cho đến xong rồi nó
sẽ nó sẽ nói chung là nó sẽ đánh dấu lại
để lấy ra toàn bộ cái cái danh sách bản
ghi phù hợp đấy mấy ông hiểu cái bài
toàn con trò đúng không ạ
thì mấy ông thấy
là đây Tôi cho mấy ông explain như
prim key tha rank Tôi không nhớ về cái
tha này
thích lắm ch nhớ về cái khoản nó có sử
dụng cái key nào để mà gọi là Index key
nào đấy và nó duyệt qua bao nhiêu bản
ghi thôi đâu thấy cha thôi tạ bỏ explain
đi
Ờ m ông cứ Hình dung là
cứ cứ qua một cái nó lại duyệt một phát
nữa cái bảng này Đấy nó chạy vòng lọp
một phát nữa bảng này và bảng này rõ
ràng là mế không thấy là cái giá trị của
cái bảng này nó có thay đổi đâu đúng
không ạ Tuy giờ nhìn ghi như thế này
thôi Nhưng mà thực ra là cái option vẫn
gần đấy option của thằng product đấy
đúng không ạ nhưng mà cứ mỗi lần cứ một
lần kiểu duyệt bản ghi này nó lại chạy
lại vòng Lạp lại phát nữa duyệt đến bản
ghi này nó lại chạy vòng lặp lại quét
lại cái bảng này phát nữa đấy nghĩa là
nó giống kiểu hai vòng lọc lầm nhau ấy
một vòng lọc là để một vòng lọp là để
kiểu duyệt từng thằng từng thằng nhá và
một vòng lặp nữa để lấy ra cái option ID
từ cái bảng product option này thì mấy
ông thấy là nó bị rất là nặng về cái
truy vấn này nó là truy vấn l lồng lồng
tức là sub nên là thường thường là hạn
chế nhất có thể cái dùng truy vấn lồng
kiểu We In kiểu như này trừ
khi trừ khi là ông truyền vào đây hẳn
một cái danh sách ID có sẵn kiểu 3 này 4
này 5 như này thì không sao cả nhưng mà
nhưng mà ông lại ghi theo kiểu như này
tức cả tức cả nó cứ duyệt từng thằng thì
nó lại truy vấn phát nữa theo như tôi
nhớ là như thế theo như tôi nhớ như thế
nên là thành ra là m Ông thấy là cái
truy vấn của ông sẽ rất rất nặng cách
cách để tối ưu hơn thứ nhất thứ nhất nhá
ít nhất là giả sử nếu mà ông không biết
không biết cách để tối ưu hơn cái câu
này thì thứ nhất là ông nên đẩy những
cái nó gọi là tr cái điều kiện mấy cái
điều kiện có vẻ là
dễ nó đỡ phức tạp hơn lên trên cái này
trước đã để nó sẽ bởi vì cái này là n mà
tức cả hai điều kiện Nó phải đúng đúng
không ạ thì mình thấy cái nào có vẻ là
xử lý nhanh hơn mình sẽ đẩy lên trước để
nếu mà Cái này có sai thì nó sẽ trả về
sớm hơn so với việc là ngồi kiểm tra này
trước thì tôi sẽ vứt cái này lên trên
chẳng
hạn đó như này thì đây gọi đỡ hơn tí rồi
đấy gọi là bớt đi một tí thôi đấy bớt đi
một tí được không ạ Nó sẽ ưu tiện nó sẽ
kiểm tra này trước để phản hồi về trước
là mình muốn loại B bỏ vài cái đi mà
đúng không Đấy đấy một cách nhưng mà
đương nhiên là như mấy ông thấy là rõ
ràng là dữ liệu này nó không bờ thay đổi
mà nó cứ Duyệt đi duyệt lại cái này nó
rất là nặng thì bây giờ mình làm như thế
nào thì bây giờ nó sẽ nhảy sang khái
niệm đó là khi mà dữ liệu không thay đổi
như này bản thân là bạn muốn lưu lại cái
này đã rồi bạn mới tính toán que nằm
trong nó thì Đấy là lúc mà mình dùng
join đấy mình dùng join join Như join
như nào thì bản thân là chính bảng này
vẫn hoàn toàn thể join Chính nó đây tôi
sẽ D Kate nó lên
rồi Product option gợi ý đi
ạ
ID
khác không không đợi Đợi tí Đợi tí
product ID bằng 2
bản này thì tôi muốn tôi muốn là cái tôi
muốn lấy dữ liệu của bản thứ nhất thôi
chẳng hạn lấy toàn bộ product ID của bản
thứ
nhất thì th product ID đợi Đợi tí Đợi tí
hồi trước tôi viết như nào
nh ID bằng product ID
này không không đúng phải là option ID
bằng option này mới đúng
ID khác
với
một tí Đợi tôi một tí đợi tôi load một
tí nhá
Ờ qu in Đúng rồi option này phải chung
option Đúng rồi PR ID này không
trung Đúng rồi
Ờ cái này bằng 2 Không Không Không nhầm
cái này bằng 2 này cái này không chung
với cái này này
Ok thử
xem Đúng rồi đấy N không thấy không ạ 35
5 3 3
đúng D nó trả về hơi nhiều à Để xem
nhá Đây là 5 này đây trả về ra 8m
chắc là nó ra tám
Ừ lấy toàn bộ product
ID khớp với cái thằng
sai option Lấy toàn bộ những cái option
khớp này không trùng với thằng này này
thực ra chỉ cần lấy khớp là được rồi ra
nhiều đấy X mình sẽ
này đúng rồi
đấy tá số lượng 8 không sao đâu không
ảnh hưởng gì không à m distance thôi mà
Đấy 35
bên này
là vẫn là 3 n đúng đúng không ạ Không
thấy hai cái kết quả như nhau không ạ
Đấy cái đoạn này nó xử lý như nào nó
phức tạp hơn rất nhiều cái này Thế nên
tôi bảo là thời gian khởi đầu là mới ông
chỉ cần hiểu đơn giản là lấy ra tất cả
các option trùng nhau à option thuộc cái
thằng product ID bằng 2 sau đó mình qu
in trong nó và đương nhiên là loại chính
cái thằng product ID 2 là được sẽ ra
được thằng 3 năm đúng không ạ Ở đây cũng
sẽ ra được 3 năm nhưng mà nó khác nhau
cái gì đây mình sẽ so sánh ở đây
là cái cái câu truy vấn này này cái câu
truy vấn này này tôi đã biến nó thành
một cái bảng nữa Tôi đặt tên là p2 này
tôi cần option ID của nó nó khớp với cái
option ID này mấy không thấy hai thằng
khớp nhau đúng không ạ Đấy và cái thằng
thằng p2 này này đương nhiên thằng p2
này này tôi sẽ qu thêm cái product ID
bằng 2 mấy ông thấy không Cái này gọi
cái này gọi là cái này gọ gọi là We hoặc
là n thì tùy mấy không thể vứt ở xuống
dưới cũng được nhưng tôi thường hay ghi
cho kiểu n như này bản thân là lúc mà Jo
ấ lúc mà Jo như này m ông thêm cái truy
vấn nằm trong on như này thì nó đã lọc
bớt dữ liệu ở trong cái cái này rồi
không phải đợi lúc ông que ở dưới như
này nữa ông que ở dưới này nó vẫn chạy
nhá đâ ông que cái này ở dưới như này nó
vẫn chạy
thôi
đây ấn này đi
này nó vẫn chạy đúng không ạ Nhưng mấy
ông sẽ thấy là là
nó nó sẽ bị nặng hơn
gọi như
nà Cái này là ông lọc dữ liệu trước rồi
ông Joi chứ không phải là ông ông Joy
Xong rồi ông mới đi lọc dữ liệu đấy đấy
là nó như thế nên là tôi sẽ những cái gì
Có thể tôi sẽ lọc trước lúc mà Jo để cho
cái bảng này sẽ rất là nhẹ trước đấy thì
ở đây ông thấy cái product ID bằng 2 đây
product ID bằng 2 đúng không ạ đây Thằng
thứ nhất này thằng thứ hai này đúng
không ạ Vẫn giống hệt mà Ừ nhưng mấy ông
đấy thêm một cái nữa Ở đây tôi thêm ở
đây Tại sao Thế bỏ đi Có chạy
không bỏ đi bỏ đi thì mấy ông thấy là nó
lại lòi ra cái thằng hai này mất rồi
đúng không
ạ bởi vì sao Bởi vì rõ ràng là nó gọi
như nà nhỉ Nó lấy nó lấy
hết đương nhiên là cả trường hợp với
việc thằng này bằng thằng này Còn nếu
không thì M mấy ông có thể Vứt cái này
xuống dưới cũng được đây vứt Hẳng xuống
dưới cũng
truy vấn trên này nhá
kiện cũng được tùy viết kiểu này cho nó
giống cái bên này không thấy hai bên
giống hệt nhau này này một bên này một
bên này đúng không ạ bây giờ chắc là tôi
thêm p1 như này nữa cho mấy ông cho
giống hệt nha
tương đối giống đúng không
Đấy Tôi đặt tên như này cho cho nó dễ
hiểu
thôi ok đây là dùng dùng Joi dùng Jo như
này tốt nhất cho bên SQL bên SQL nó bản
thân nó sinh nó kiểu dạng như rất tối ưu
về cho Joi ấ và trong trường hợp này như
tôi vừa nãy nói
Ừ
đây khi mà ông duyệt từng bản ghim một ấ
thì thì nó nếu mà trong trường hợp này
thì nó cứ lặp đi lặp lại cái này đúng
không ạ Còn bên này thì không Bên này
bản chất là nó đã tạo ra hẳn một cái
bảng như thế này rồi không phải tạo ra
bảng mà nó cho chính cái bảng vật lý đây
hai bảng vật lý
này nó nó nó lưu lại sẵn dữ điệu đấy
Xong rồi nó cứ thế mà chi vào rồi nó que
thôi nên là nó không bao giờ bị lặp lại
như th này nữa kiểu truy vần nó không bị
lặp lại nữa ấ thế nên là nó sẽ trả ra
được dữ liệu rất là nhanh đương nhiên là
đây Tôi đang ít dữ liệu nên mấy ông thấy
tốc độ nó nganh nhau chẳng vấn đề gì cả
Đây thử x explain
nha explain
này
Ừ đây không ghi tốc độ nên mấy không khó
mà biết được
lắm 7 r này 73 xem bên này nó tôi vẫn
chưa thử explain cái này cái
gì đây
emp này tạo ra một cái bảng tạm này
ờ
nhìn row ở đây đều là 3 này bên
này Đợi tí Đợi
tí bên này một bên 7 một bên 3 này m ông
thấy không ạ Đấy cái tha của nó tha vừa
rồi tha cái này primary K à primary à
Cái này nó là se là symbol là tốt nhất
này còn cái này primary này primary Tôi
nhớ nó là cái cũng kiểu phải ưu tiên cái
thằng nào trước cái thằng nào sau
đâu pro Thế á th tra lại nhá không Tôi
nhớ có lặp lại
Đợi tí đợi
lớn nhất từ bảng product Ừ đúng nếu mà
ghi kiểu này thì nó sẽ lấy ra để
suất dữ liệu từ bảng ho nhiều bảng của
một chi vần chính
không chắc là có mà Đúng không mấy kiến
thức cơ bản nó phải biết mà đúng không
Nếu
tôi dùng sub
để truy
vấn đây lấy hẳn Ví dụ như này
vấn duyệt từng bản ghi đúng không có bị
lặ
lại truy vấn
vào bảng trong sub
không hay là chỉ truy vấn một lần rồi sử
dụng kết quả
đó à tôi tạo một cái con sqr assist này
mà quên chưa trả lời về cơ bản hiệu suất
phụ thuộc vào cách
thức được thực thi một lần
một lần hay
dữ liệu của try vấn Chính
Ừ thực thi nhiều
lần Ừ tôi nhớ về cái vụ thực thi nhiều
lần bởi vì nó có phụ thuộc vào cái truy
phần chính còn nếu mà nếu mà không phụ
thuộc như này Ừ chắc là nó sẽ thực thi
một một lần
khả năng thực khi sub lưu kết quả Ồ cũng
được cũng được tuy nhiên điều này cũng
phụ thuộc vào cụ thể dbms đang sử dụng Ừ
đấy vẫn phải dùng explain để
xem cái explain này tôi nghĩ
là có thể có thể đây có thể nó sẽ sử
dụng bảng tạm như bạn bảo có thể truy
vấn một lần Ừ thế Thế thì tính ra nó vẫn
Ừ nó vẫn có thể đỡ đi phần nào Theo tôi
là nó vẫn đỡ đi phần nào vì bản chất
nhá Không không không như tôi đã bảo thì
thực ra sub tôi từng tra rất nhiều subg
Không Không thể nhanh hơn Joy được đây
Joy
à Joy so với
subquery We In thì cái
nào nhanh hơn trong
ra cái cái Khi mà mình truy vấn quay in
Thì mình vẫn có thể dùng Index Tôi không
biết về cái việc tận dụng tốt hơn hay
không nhưng mà Ờ tôi từng tra khá nhiều
Và trên stack flow Hồi đấy cũng thường
ha trả lời là kiểu Joi tối ưu hơn này
hiệu thường hiệu quả hơn Ồ với bảng lớn
Ừ nó đề cập cụ thể là với bạn lớn có thể
nhanh hơn với bạn nhỏ
cái này nó vẫn đang không chắc chắn đúng
không ạ Ok nếu không chắc chắn thì mình
cứ gọi là chỉ tham khảo thôi mình có thể
sử dụng như tôi đang bảo là mình có thể
sử dụng kiểu We In để mà làm mọi thứ
kiểu dạng đơn giản dễ hiểu hơn cách này
là cách gọi là cơ bản nhất đúng không ạ
chứ chưa ngồi ghi Joi kiểu này mình cũng
hơi khó hiểu và về sau khó sửa bởi vì
mình không hiểu nên không sửa đấy
Ờ khi mà ghi code ấy thì mấy ông Thực ra
có thể lấy ra toàn bộ ID này xong ông qu
in để ch chắc chắn nhất chứ không a
không qu kiểu này nữa vì vì như tôi vừa
nãy nói là cái gì nhỉ
ờ cái việc là truy vấn nhiều lần như này
à truy vấn như Bảo ấy ở trên này này nó
thực thi một lần hay nhiều lần ấy nó phụ
thuộc vào cái database của
ông Đúng là đúng là cái vụ thực thi một
lần này thì lần đầu tôi nghe này nhưng
mà có thể nó đúng bởi vì là thường là
hồi trước là tôi khi mà dùng subc ấ khi
mà subc kiểu này này tôi toàn thường ha
phụ thuộc vào cái bảng Bảng này phụ
thuộc cái bảng lớn này này ví dụ là kiểu
à
np1 kiểu đấy bằng như này chẳng hạn giả
s à không không phải kiểu Giả sử là kiểu
như
này khác như này chẳng hạn
đấy ví dụ như này nó phụ thuộc về cái
bảng này này
thuộc vào cái bảng này nữa thì nó sẽ là
cái subc truy vấn nhiều lần đấy chứ
không còn là thực thi một lần nữa bởi vì
đây là cái câu truy vấn đơn giản là quay
thẳng như này cái cái dữ cái kết quả này
nó không thay đổi Nên là thành ra là cái
này có thể là một lần có thể một lần
thôi nhá Bởi vì là tôi nhớ Tôi nhớ chính
xác đó là cái database đôi khi nó không
thông minh cho
lắm có khi nó có khi rất nhiều lúc là
thông minh nghĩa là nó sử dụng đúng edex
mình cần đúng truy vấn kiểu gọi như là
cách xử lý của cái dat của cái nó gọi là
không phải là database đâu Nó là dpms
này
này cách xử lý của dpms nó sẽ tìm được
con đường thực thi tối ưu và ngắn ngắn
nhất thường là như thế
nhưng mà nhưng mà nó sẽ đánh đổi là có
rất nhiều cái có đôi khi là nhiều lúc nó
không tìm được đúng đường mình một là
mình phải for phải bắt nó phải đi đúng
cái con đường mình muốn không thì gọi
nhiều lúc nó đi đường dài ấy chứ nó
không phải lúc nào nó cũng tố ưu đâu đấy
Nên là nếu mình không biết cách thì tốt
nhất là mình không nên ghi những cái câu
truy vấn quá phức tạp giống như là bên
join này là rất là phức tạp này bên này
làm cái gì đơn giản nhất Tuy là nhìn
trông nó dài róng hơn dài Gióng hơn bên
này nhá Nhưng mà mình biết cách thì mình
kiểm soát được
đấy đây là đây vừa rồi tôi vừa nói về
cái Joy đúng không Thực ra còn cả Joy
sub nữa nhưng mà tôi sợ là mấy ông Ừ Ít
ra có một ông Aron này ở đây thì chắc là
con
hiểu giờ tôi thử nói nốt về cái Joy sub
nhá Đây ờ ừ í ra có ông Aron ở đây con
nghe nghe V hiểu tôi đang nói gì cũng an
ủi được tưởng nãy giờ mình đang độc
thoại OK
bây giờ trong trường hợp
này
đây sẽ để bên này
đi
vấn join này
đầu tiên thì như tôi đã nói là theo tôi
theo tôi thì join này nó vẫn tối tối ưu
và nhanh hơn so với thằng thằng subquery
này và nó cũng gọi là khá hiệu quả Với
SQL nhưng mà nhưng mà sẽ có nhiều lúc là
mình sẽ dùng sử dụng trường hợp Jo SH
này đặc biệt là khi mình viết code tại
sao như thế Cái này Thực ra chắc là tôi
phải đề cập đến code thì mấy ông mới dễ
hình dung ra được Tại sao tự nhiên mình
phải dùng Joy sub cái này nó liên quan
đến bên larel khi mà viết code Thực ra
larel nó vẫn là gọi nhở hỗ trợ mình à
gọi là đ năng thôi chứ không kiểu có
nhiều tính năng ha các th thứ và viết
code nó dễ chứ Không hề tốt về cái hiệu
năng Ví dụ ở toàn bộ những cái kiểu
relationship của nó thường là kiểu
subquery kiểu như này chứ không có cái
nào là join cả nên thành ra nó hiệu năng
nó không tốt khi mà truy
vấn tiếp theo là là nếu mà join như này
ấ đây tôi thử viết lại hai cái này theo
kiểu code trong lel thì mình dễ hình
dung hơn nhá
mà nếu mà mình viết kiểu không phải
subquery thì mình sẽ viết theo kiểu như
này
này bằng product option này
lấy product ID À nhầm option ID đúng
không ạ option
ID option ID này
đó rồi Tiếp theo là mình lấy
[âm nhạc]
tí Hình như là comment ở đây nó sẽ gợi ý
code cho mình thì phải thử
nhá
rồi Bây giờ tôi thử Return nó
Ờ đợi tí đợi
tí V ch nh bán
file hình như là bởi vì tôi chưa khai
báo cái thằng
này đợi t đợi t cái này
http
à sẽ có cái prefix như
mình có Mew gì À
xem
luôn ạ
này đ
t xóa thử midare đi xem
product ID này và mình sẽ truy vấn w in
như này Đây đây cũng rất là nhanh theo
kiểu là nhưng mà nó là hai hai câu truy
vấn độc lập nha Đây là cách viết theo
kiểu viết code thì thay vì kiểu mấy ông
ờ ghi ghi theo kiểu dạng như này select
một cụm như này w in trong select cầm
một cụm như này thì mấy ông có thể ghi
theo kiểu lấy ra dữ liệu trước như này
xong mông We In như này ok không ạ đây
một
cách một cách
test 1 đi Đấy cách nữa tôi sẽ ghi kiểu
cho như này cho mấy ông copy
là Return
ồ đấy nó sẽ gợi ý như này thường tôi sẽ
ghi kiểu như này
nhá
đấy thường tôi ghi kiểu như
này Đây là test 1 rồi chạy lại thử xem
nhá
ai c pilot nó gợi ý cho mấy ông mấy ông
cứ comment như này thôi nó sẽ gợi ý code
larel cho mấy ông này chuẩn luôn Ồ Bây
giờ tôi biết cái khái niệm form này hay
phết để đặt tên cho cái bản ừm
hiểu select này cho này qu lance này Ok
trông có vẻ hợp lý
không ạ Kết quả nó vẫn đúng câu truy vấn
này Đấy Ok không ạ mặc định Joy sẽ inner
Joy này này
đó nó
sẽ giống với cái câu trú vấn này vừa nãy
mình
viết nhưng ở đây mấy ông đang thấy thưa
thằng larel nó có hỗ trợ việc chi thuần
như này nhưng nhưng nó không
tốt không tốt cái gì Nó là kiểu dạng là
mình Ông thấy là nó ghi lại rõ cái
tên tên bảng là một Tôi thấy là nó một
nhược điểm rồi cái nhược điểm thứ hai đó
là nếu M mấy ông để ý thực ra là nó gọi
là như nó không tận dụng lại cái mod này
ở trong cái thằng join Thứ hai này nó
không join vào cái mod tức là thì đương
nhiên trong trường hợp này thường là ông
ghi lại tên bản thế chắc cũng đủ rồi ông
không ông không dùng table của chính là
modle khai báo nữa không kại tên bảng
chắc là về sau không đổi tên bảng đâu
không đổi tên cột đâu Nên chắc cũng
không phải lo nhưng mà không Đôi khi nó
sẽ ôm rất nhiều cái mod đồ của ông nó có
sẽ thêm rất nhiều cái khác nữa nó sẽ đi
kèm ví dụ ví dụ ở đây sẽ cho thêm một
cột nữa Để mấy ông dễ hình dung hơn tôi
sẽ có thêm một
này
à là time stem đúng không
đúng không ạ đy cột như này đúng không ạ
à sử với thằng 3 cho
hết thời gian này
à à Ok enter này à thôi thằng ba có vẻ
nhiều
quá
đi thằng nă đi Enter đấy thằng Nghĩa
thằng nă bị xóa đúng không ạ đúng không
ạ Tôi sẽ u shop Delete ở
đây
này đầu tiên thì tôi chạy với cái trường
hợp trường hợp trên này đã nhá Bây giờ
tôi đổi lại cái này là test 2 và đây Bỏ
test đi nhá trường hợp trên này nó vẫn
sẽ đúng
nữa vì thằng năm bị xóa D tt ấ rồi mà
đúng không ạ sẽ bị xóa đi Chỉ còn thằng
ba
thôi Lâu ấ nhỉ À Có mỗi thằng ba thôi
này chạy
rồi chạy câu truy vấn kiểu như này thì
thì nó luôn có khi mà ông thêm một cái
chết kiểu như này hoặc là một cái Global
Scope cho thằng mod thì tức cả chị là nó
sẽ luôn que thêm một cái điều kiện nữa
trong trường hợp này là điều kiện là là
không được phép xóa đúng không ạ Đấy thì
nó luôn thêm vào nên là truy vấn của ông
ra đ mỗi thằng ba tức là đúng đấy nhưng
mà b tôi thay vào đó là đây Xóa cái test
này đi
đy Tôi chạy thì mấy ông sẽ thấy
đợi tí tôi nghĩ là tôi sẽ bỏ cái form
table này đi đấy Đấy nó còn đang bị lỗi
vì tôi để kẻ add này cho cái này thì
thành ra cái cột ấ nó không hiểu là của
cái bảng nào xóa này đi
như thế phải ghi lại
cả dùng cả livestream nên thà nó bị
product ID này chấm
bị con à
Đây nó vẫn
ra Ừ đúng đúng trong trường hợp này nó
vẫn ra bởi vì nó lấy theo dựa theo thằng
này mà Ừ nhỉ đúng rồi nó vẫn dựa đ thằng
product option này nên là đ nó vẫn có
đúng rồi tôi viết kiểu ngược lại
đi tô cho là thằng thằng này mới là
thằng bằng 2
đây
và thằng này thằng khác hai đi thằng này
thằng khác hai
này Thằng này mới thằng bằng 2 này
Đấy và lấy ra toàn bộ những cái product
ID product 2
ạ truy vật nó sẽ là như nào nó vẫn sẽ là
distance như này nó cái thằng Tuy là tuy
là Jo hai thằng với nhau như này đúng
không ạ Nhưng mấy ông Để ý kỹ thì chỉ có
mỗi thằng product option này cái đ Ất nó
là nun thôi à Không không được kiểu Ừ
nghĩ đ Ất là n tức là kiểu dạng là nó
không được phép xóa đúng không ạ nhưng
mà cái thằng thằng p2 này này nó không
hề kiểm tra việc là nó đã bị xóa hay
chưa đúng không ạ Thế bây giờ làm thế
nào Làm thế nào để mình mình tận dụng
lại được thằng mod này mình không phải
viết lại tên tên bảng nữa là một thứ hai
đó là tận dụng lại được những cái Scope
này thì đấy là khái niệm mà mình sẽ dùng
khái niệm thằng larel nó có làm nó là
join sub đây nó như này anh em mà biết
cách nào Tôi ưu hơn thì thử bảo tôi nhé
Tôi ch tôi biết cách này thôi th xem nào
Nó sẽ là kiểu tôi sẽ tạo ra một cái
thằng product option
thường là tôi sẽ chỉ lấy cái cột Tôi cần
thôi tôi sẽ là select cái cột Tôi cần
thôi như
này và We product
ID này khác
bây giờ thay vì join bình thường như này
tôi sẽ là choi sub đó và đây prod p2
này Đấy nó sẽ ch P2 như này rồi p2 các
thứ thứ như này vẫn giống hệt cái vừa
nãy đây sẽ là test và đây đổi thành test
g gì đó đúng không
ạ
tôi thử chạy thử mấy không
đấy không phải dễ đâu nhưng mà gọi
như Đợi tí Đợi tí à Đúng rồi cả cái cột
option này nữa thôi bỏ select đi lấy
bằng 3
nhá đây mấy ông thấy là nó đã nó đã có
một cái bảng nữa đây là cho sub bản chất
là nó sẽ tạo một cái bảng tem một bảng
Ảo khác nó không và nó sẽ có thêm cái
det Ất này cái này cũng có det Ất này
cái này cũng có det Ất này bởi vì là nó
sẽ khi mà ông Khi mà ông gọi đến cái
model lại như thế này
này thì nó sẽ sử dụng tận dụng lại được
tên bảng này sử dụng lại được cái cái
Scope các thứ thứ của cái thằng mod đấy
Nên là nên là đấy là một cách kiểu dạng
là của của larel thôi ta để tận dụng lại
được các thứ thứ với thằng mồ đấy đ bao
gồm ở l nên thành ra là truy vấn nó sẽ
đúng nhưng
mà nhưng mà như tôi đã nói thằng larel
làm kiểu này nó có cái dở Gần đây tôi
được anh tôi chia sẻ đó là khi mà khi mà
join sub kiểu như này nhá Khi mà truy
vấn kiểu như này mấy ông thấy là ừ thế
này cũng được không dùng join nữa dùng
join sub đi để cho tận dụng lại cái mu
đồ đúng không ạ Nhưng mà nó có nhược
điểm là như tôi bảo đấy nó là tạo ra một
cái bảng ảo như này tức là cái câu truy
vấn lúc mà ông chạy câu truy vấn ấy nó
chiếm khá nhiều tài nguyên việc là nó
lưu thêm một cái dữ liệu Ảo nữa rồi về
sau đương nhiên là câu này chạy Xong thì
nó cũng bị mất hôi nhưng mà tự nhiên là
lúc đấy Cái bộ nhớ nó bị tăng lên ấy nên
là thực ra là không hẳn là khuyến khích
về việc join sub nên là cách tối ưu nhất
tôi thường hay làm vẫn là tôi dùng Joy
sau đó nhưng mà chắc chắn là phải là
mình phải nhớ về mấy cái vụ đ tật Ất
giống như tôi vừa nói và các thứ thứ đấy
sau rồi Không thì mấy ông cứ chơi thuần
cho tôi là que In cũng được hoặc là tách
hẳn câu chy vấn ra cũng được À bởi bởi
vì về các bạn nếu mà ông We In đúng cái
cột có đánh Index thì thc ra nó vẫn
nhanh
thôi Nhưng mà nếu mà Mấy ông muốn tối ưu
hết sức có thể thì đúng là dùng join là
tốt nhất sau đó thì mới đến que in còn
cái Joy sub này thì tôi cảm thấy nó tốn
nó Joy sub này nó theo tôi đánh giá nó
vẫn nhanh bằng cái join này nhưng mà nó
tốn thêm cái quả tốn bộ nhớ này n tôi
không đề cao nà lắm cái join này thì
không tốn bội nhớ vì bản chất là cái
bảng đấy nó có rồi nên ông tận dụng lại
chỉnh cái bảng này thôi nế nó không
không kiểu sử dụng thêm cái bộ nhớ đấy
là theo kiến thức tôi biết nhá tất cả
toàn bộ vẫn là kiến thức tôi biết theo
kiểu là tôi thực hành và Đ kết và có đọc
thêm tài liệu nhưng mà còn việc là gọi
tài liệu thì chính chính xác là kiểu nó
có uy tín hay không Vân Vân Vân thì tôi
chưa chuyên sâu đến thế về bản thân là
như nào vẫn tính ra mình vẫn không được
đào tạo một cách bài bản và không ai dạy
cách bài bản toàn bộ mấy cái đấy cả chủ
yếu vẫn là mình Ừ chắc là có những kiến
thức là phải đọc thêm về sách nhưng mà
đúng không Hơi l đọc sách Tôi cũng chỉ
đọc chủ yếu là tài liệu trên mạng và và
gặp vấn đề thì tôi tra Google thôi Nên
là khó mà gọi là gọi là như
nào thông tin được kiểm chứng à
nhưng mà cá nhân kiến thức của tôi như
tôi đã bảo đó là kiến thức của tôi đế B
giờ vẫn áp dụng được vẫn làm được việc
và vẫn tối ưu các thứ thứ vẫn xị chẳng
qua là đi trả lời phỏng vấn thì không
biết trả lời một cái câu về gọi như là
hiểu rõ hơn ví dụ Giả sử bạn đây vừa nãy
hỏi về cái H index thì chắc là chịu này
hay là kiểu Tại sao Tại sao không trả
lời được mấy cái câu đấy thật đôi khi là
mấy ông gọi nhờ m không cần biết mấy cái
điều đấy vẫn có thể làm được việc tôi
cảm thấy là đánh giá như thế Tôi dạy ở
đây dạy mấy ông vẫn là thứ nhất là về tư
duy lập trình thứ hai là dạy về cách
thực hành là nhiều hơn còn về kiến thức
kiểu sâu rộng kiến thức kiểu sâu hơn ấy
chuyên sâu hơn thì chắc là mấy ông phải
tự học thôi Tôi không dạy được mấy ông
mấy cái điều đấy đấy ok nhở ủi hôm nay
Ừ hỏi mấy loại Index chịu luôn đúng
ông về Index nhở tôi cũng nói qua mấy
ông về cái kiểu mấy cái Index kiểu phổ
biến rồi ấ
chứ OK ở buổi hôm nay mang tiếng định
chia sẻ rất rất nhiều nhưng mà có vẻ là
mấy cái này tôi muốn giải thích kỹ hơn
cho mấy ông Thành là nó cũng
hơi
sao Ừ tôi nhớ Tôi có theo dõi v cái kênh
nói về cái Index chuyên sâu à Mấy cái
phải Index rồi các thử thứ tôi định học
tham gia m khóa học thêm mà xo thì người
ta đòn trên sâu
ờ ừ nếu mà đấy ở trong gọi như à Tôi
chưa làm ở công ty tập đoàn lớn ấ không
biết như nà nhá Nhưng mà tôi biết ở mấy
công ty nhỏ ấy Thực ra là mình gọi là
nha mình tính ra mình vẫn chỉ là lập
trình viên thôi Thì thực ra là mình vẫn
gần như gần như là mình sẽ chỉ cần gọi
là Ui biết về mấy cái choi chung các thứ
select ra xong rồi subquery Cũng xịn rồi
cũng làm được việc
rồi còn lên cái Ông làm ở tập đoàn lớn
ấy thì thực ra chuẩn là ông không được
truy vấn thẳng vào DB như thế này đâu để
mà để mà chết à Kiểu ông không biết V
tối ưu câu truy vấn ông truy vấn vào
những cái kiểu cơ sự dữ liệu kểu lên đến
tỷ BN ghi mà ông truy vấn kiểu không
không biết Cột nào đã đánh Index rồi qu
lúng ta tung lên thì chỉ có chết
database nhà người ta đúng không ạ Đấy
Tôi từng thử thế một phát rồi nên là
triệu bạn trăm triệu Bạn ghi đã chết rồi
nhá ch tỷ nhá nên là à lúc đấy thì nếu
ông vẫn làm đép thì thực ra ông không
cần phải biết đều đấy quá sâu Còn nếu mà
ông muốn lên hàm cái vị trí khác cao hơn
lương cao hơn hấp dẫn hơn mấy ông biết
là database mấy ông thích động và
database kiểu thế thì chắc chắn là kiến
thức của ông phải hiểu về cốt lõi của
vấn đề nữa hiểu về kiểu tại sao nó lại
như thế Vân Vân Vân hiểu rõ bản chất hơn
thì tôi Ừ thực ra hôm nay tôi cũng định
tâm sự về cái vụ đấy luôn Tôi định để
cuối này cơ đó là hôm
trước tôi đi bây giờ đến giờ tâm sự rồi
mà xin phép tâm sự một tí nhá Hôm trước
cái người
anh của tôi anh
đấy xuất thân là dân kinh tế nhưng mà
anh đấy Kiểu cũng nhảy sang
bên bên lập trình và cũng kiểu bây giờ
công nghệ ông tin nói chung Đấy anh Đấy
là tôi theo dõi ở trên vi một người rất
rất nổi tiếng cũng kiểu là diễn giả viết
bài Khá hay Khá cuốn Hình như tôi từng
chia sẻ mấy ông hai ba bài của anh đấy
rồi trên kipalog đấy
đấy thì anh đấy hỏi tôi cái câu là là em
về sau em muốn đi dậy à và đặc biệt là
có thể làm diễn giả nữa thì em Em là con
người Kiểu Học rộng hay học
sâu hôm đấy Tôi không trả lời được câu
đấy
Tôi cảm thấy là
kiểu chuẩn giống như là tôi cũng hơi hơi
Gọi
nhà dậm chân tại chỗ thì chắc cũng đúng
kiểu ràng là cũng cảm thấy cái cái đầu
mình mang tiếng mình th hay nói là mình
cũng có cái cái đầu mở kiểu suy nghĩ
cười Mở thoáng Nhưng mà thực ra mình
không mở lắm tính ra đấy ví dụ mấy ông
thấy là tôi vẫn thường hay bảo thủ vẫn
cố chấp quả peer stone vẫn không dùng vs
code đến bây giờ vẫn chỉ biết một vài
ngôn ngữ lập trình như là pp và
JavaScript kiểu thế và tôi vẫn không hẳn
là muốn chuyên sâu về lập trình mà tôi
muốn hướng đến về database nhưng mà cũng
cũng chưa dành về database giống như ông
kia nói đó là chưa dành về kiểu dạng là
thực sự kiến trúc dữ liệu hay là mọi thứ
của nó đấy nghĩa là để mà nói mình về
sau mình đi dạy thì dạy mấy kiến thức cơ
bản mình vẫn dạy được còn để mà nói sâu
hơn kiểu kiểu học sinh hỏi xoáy hơn ý
Kiểu các thứ thứ có khi mình chắc chắn
là rất nhiều câu mình không trả lời được
cũng như là hỏi mình về những kiến thức
ngoài lề khác thì kiểu là những cái mảng
khác mà mình đã thì có rất nhiều cái
mạng mình chưa động vào chưa làm rất
nhiều bạn nhiều lúc mà hỏi tôi mấy câu
tôi toàn phải nói là tôi chưa động vào
bên
đấy Nên là nên là tôi giống như tôi
thường chia sẻ với mấy ông mà thực ra
tôi thực hành nhiều hơn tôi cảm thấy là
tôi không Tôi hơi khó không phải khó tập
trung mà
và kiểu dạng là ngấm ngấm được nó rất là
nhanh ấy tôi hoàn toàn Tôi thích sách
Tôi có thể đọc sách nhưng mà tôi ngấm nó
không nhanh được như nhiều người
tôi phải đọc à Tôi cũng rất hí đọc sách
nhưng mà mỗi khi đọc thì không phải bị
buồn ngủ đâu Tôi không bị buồn ngủ khi
đọc sách th ra may như thế rất nhiều cái
may hơn một vài người nhưng mà để mà đọc
thấm nhuẩn nó và thực hành tôi nghĩ phải
tôi quen l việc thực hành hơn là việc
đọc lý thuyết kiểu kiểu thế Có rất có
nhiều người phù hợp việc học lý thuyết
Điền hình là mấy ông ở bên Bách Hoa
Chẳng hạn Ui mấy ông ấy học lý thuyết
rất là đỉnh có thể nghiền ngẫm chuyên
sâu một cái gì đó
à đặc biệt là tôi cảm thấy là những
người hướng nội rất phù hợp với việc đấy
thế hoàn toàn thể nghiền ngẫn Nghiên cứu
sâu V một vấn đề nên là cái lý thuyết
cái nền của họ rất là đỉnh Tôi cảm thấy
thế thôi Ờ Còn tôi thì tôi vẫn thấy mình
hơi hướng ngoại Tức là mình à khó mà
ngồi lâu để đọc một cái tài liệu gì Thì
đó Mình vẫn thích thực hành mình vẫn
thích kiểu dạng là thực chiến hơn nên
nên là lý thuyết mình nhiều lúc mình
không vững lắm Mình gọi là chỉ đủ để
dùng và làm rồi thì mình mới vỡ lễ ra
chứ không không phải là mình nắm chắc lý
thuyết bản chất vấn đề của nó nên đôi
khi là mình đi nó hơi bị đường vòng và
đôi khi Thậm chí còn đi sai
đấy Nên là đương nhiên là mình cũng phải
mình biết được nhược điểm mình đấy mình
cũng phải cải thiện nên là gần đây là
tôi nghĩ là tôi sẽ
phải
cũng bảo tôi là tôi bị giới hạn môi
trường Nếu kiểu là tôi làm tôi làm ở
công ty này thì nó
nó nó kiểu dạng là chỉ vẫn là áp dụng
cái ngôn ngữ mà tôi hay làm thế thành ra
là kiểu mình vẫn đang gọi là cũng đang ở
trong một vùng an toàn ở đó mình
không không có cơ hội để mở mang thêm
kiến thức không ép mình phải mở mang
thêm kiến thức gì cả đấy Nên là chắc là
tôi vẫn sẽ phải làm thêm nhiều ngôn ngữ
khác để mà mình có cái góc nhìn xa hơn
và
khó học sâu giống như tôi vừa đề cập thì
sẽ biết được Kiểu thế mạnh của từng ngôn
ngữ chẳng hạn thực ra là đương nhiên tôi
cũng biết ra scrip một tí nhưng mà vẫn
kiểu vẫn còn gọi là ngại động vào nó bởi
vì kiểu nó bên fen thì nó liên quan đến
cả giáo diện nữ hơi ngại nhưng
mà chắc là mình sẽ phải biết thêm ra
Script này x Java chẳng hạn học Java rất
là hay nhá học Java để mà kiểu dạng là
nó là ngôn ngữ Nó chắt chẽ hơn pp rất
nhiều pp tính ra nó vẫn rất là dễ học mà
đấy giống như anh ấy bảo là để làm quen
bởi vì pp cách xử lý nó sẽ tuần tự còn
Java nó kiểu dạng là kiểu gì à
nó là song song à nhớ nó là đa luồng hay
gì gì đó còn ra scrip thì nó là bất Tần
tự đấy anh chưa học ra scrip
à Tôi có
nó mới chuyên về op mạnh hơn pp cũng có
Op Nhưng mà kiểu dạng là gọi nh nó không
chặt chễ và nó kiểu cũng gọi nh nó có
nó không triệt để được ấy
đấy đúng rồi đấy x rồi Học câu Lang nữa
các th thứ nữa tôi vẫn nhớ là kiểu anh
em ở trong cộng đồng larel p Nói chung
ấy kiểu rất thường kiểu thỉnh thoảng đá
ra Kiểu cái cái vấn cái vấn đề này giải
quyết bằng g Lang nhanh lắm
đấy N không chỉ
là hàm chỉ kiểu rõ ràng là là mình cảm
thấy tự nhiên tự nhiên mình bị gò bó
mình vào một cái công nghệ hay một cái
ngôn ngữ gì đó ấy đấy tự nhiên mình làm
giảo cản mình rồi đấy tôi nghĩ thế nên
là bây giờ chắc là lúc chắc là chưa muộn
đâu nấy lúc mình cũng phải kiểu bước ra
khỏi vùng an toàn năm nay thì tôi cũng
Thực ra tôi từng hứa mấy ông Năm ngoái
năm kia rồi đó là tôi sẽ kiểu làm cái
tiện ích rồi làm mấy cái trang web các
thứ thứ bây giờ tôi sẽ tự bước ra vùng
an toàn Mình sẽ kiểu dùng ngôn ngữ khác
để làm những cái điều đấy đấy để vừa làm
vừa học luôn để nói chung là Ừ mình cải
thiện thêm trình độ
mình may là bây giờ mình vẫn còn tuổi
trẻ vẫn còn thời gian mình không nên
kiểu dạng là đã trẻ mà vẫn còn trẻ mà
mình đã bảo thủ thì không tốt đúng không
ạ Mình nên có cái đầu rất là mở tôi đã
dạy mấy ông về cái đầu mở nhưng chính
tôi cũng đóng nên là thnh ra thế nó cũng
sai đúng không ạ Chúng ta cùng ừ làm s
livestream học
livestream Lúc mà tôi tôi tôi vẫn ý định
là tôi vẫn sẽ làm làm cái trang trang
web bằng p lel sau đó thì có cả mongo DB
nữa mongo à hoặc elect Search thì thực
ra Elec cũng là cái thứ mà tôi từng áp
dụng Tôi đang không biết được tôi định
thử m m nhưng mà mongo hình như là không
biết về cái việc search full search ph
full search tex nó ổn bằng etic search
hay không Nói chung là tôi sẽ nói chung
là tôi vẫn định làm trước bằng larel nói
chung nhưng mà lục làm xong trang web
làm trang web thì tôi vẫn định bằng
lavel với view nhá vcs sau đó thì tôi sẽ
làm app ở trên điện thoại thì tôi sẽ học
Java để để mà làm app trên điện thoại
đấy tôi định là thế nếu mà app trên điện
thoại Java thì chắc là Android sẽ chạy
trước sau đó nếu mà làm xong Android rồi
thì có thể nhảy sang bên à bên
à Dùng react để làm app ở trên
IOS COD lin
làm đấy chứ thôi Tôi đang muốn học Java
nà nên C làm bằng Java JAV tôi tôi nhớ
là Java nhảy được hết
đúng không Nhưng mà thôi Tôi tôi đã bảo
tôi muốn có cái cớ để mà học Java rồi
mấy ông l nhảy lại bảo tôi nhảy sang
ngôn ngữ khác thế
Buồn như trước mắt là vẫn phải làm cái
dự án đấy
đã đấy bằng cứ cho larel trước để thấy
mạnh
Ừ đúng còn không thì dùng làm làm app x
nhúng code web là xong nhưng mà thôi Thế
lại lười
là như thế tôi kiểu dạng là mình mình
phát triển có thể cố cố trong năm nay mà
được cái web đã còn app thì chưa Hướng
hẹ được cái web đấy như tôi từng nói mấy
không hôm sáng nãy tôi mới định hướng
lại là thức ra hồi trước tôi định làm
web chia sẻ nhạc nhưng mà tôi nghĩa là
tôi sẽ rộng ra không phải mỗi chia sẻ
nhạc mà nó sẽ chia sẻ gần như là kiểu
video trên YouTube này luôn Tức là chỉ à
Ừ chắc là tôi sẽ nói sâu với nó hơn sau
ừm
Chào bạn chào bạn
Ờ Ừ nhưng mà tôi cảm thấy là định hướng
của mình C vẫn đang đi được đúng hướng
ngĩ là về khoản sự nghiệp là gặp được
đúng người đấy gặp gặp người anh đấy để
anh đấy đưa những lời khuyên các thứ thứ
thì mình kiểu mình biết được là mình gọi
như nào hôm trước tôi nhớ là có cái cái
đấy mấy không biết mấy ông biết không Nó
kiểu Tạ là mình thường hay nói những thứ
mình biết đúng không ạ
Tôi không biết tra kiểu gì cơ
nói điều mình
men Minh mon
men đây vi Min m men Hồi trước trên cái
Block nữa anh ấy mặt ngoài đời giống hết
Này này kiểu cũng kiểu tròn chính đáng
yêu và kiểu hay
Ờ nói những điều mình biết này
à gọi nhở người ta sẽ nói mình những
điều mình chưa biết à à Không đâu đâ để
tôi tôi nhớ Có cái có cái ảnh hồi trước
tôi từng nghe cái đấy nói những mình
biết này à biết là mình chưa biết cái gì
này đúng không nhỉ À biết mình thiếu
những cái gì
đấy Và thậm chí là mình còn à gì nh Tôi
nhớ nó có bốn cái cơ bốn cái ảnh một cái
là nói những điều mình biết Ờ là một
ok nói những điều mình biết đúng không ạ
Và
à đâu phải là
biết mình biết gì đấy và biết mình thiếu
gì
gì cái từ là gì Tôi C Không nhớ cơ m
không biết cái này không ạ Biết kh mấy
cái khái niệm này không ạ n dạy gì thì
anh à Vừa rồi anh dạy qua SQL rồi còn
bây giờ chỉ tâm sự thôi
Ờ mếu không biết mấy khái niệm này không
ạ tôi tôi còn không nhớ cái thứ tư là
cái
hiểu nhá Biết mình biết gì Ví dụ Giả sử
Tôi nói tôi biết pp chẳng hạn biết mình
thiếu gì đấy Giả sử là tôi nghĩ là tôi
kém về cái Java thì tôi nghĩa là tôi sẽ
phải học thêm Java đấy tôi biết được tôi
thiếu gì đúng không ạ Chưa biết mình
thiếu gì Cái này này mới là cái mà kiểu
Ông cần khai phá bản thân
kiểu kiểu kiểu kiểu dạng là ông còn
không biết được là mình thiếu điều đấy
Cho đến hôm mà anh ấy nói tôi thì tôi
mới biết được là ừ Uầy Hóa ra em Thiếu
cái đấy mà từ trước đến nay em không hề
biết được em thiếu em nghĩ em Chỉ đơn
giản em thiếu mỗi Java thôi chẳng ạn tự
nhiên anh ấy nói là kiểu dạng kiểu khai
sáng hơn kiểu Ngôn ngữ này thì đáng lẽ
cái ngôn ngữ này hiển nhiên em phải biết
mà bây giờ em lại không biết à đấy Kiểu
thế chẳng hạn thế đấy đấy đ chưa biết
mình thiếu gì đấy Bạn bạn nói chuyện sao
cho mà bạn nói chuyện đ với người mài
người có thể khai phá là cho bạn cả
những điều mà kiểu đáng lẽ bạn phải biết
đấy còn tôi không nhớ cái thứ tư là cái
gì
cơi không biết tra kiểu gì hay thử khỏi
chvt nhỉ ờ có bốn trường
còn
mà tôi nhớ mỗi ba cái
này còn cái nào nữa bổ sung giúp
đấy đấy Uầy Chat
đấy đây cái vùng trạng thái mà mà mình
biết được mình cái gì đấy play spot này
unn này Đấy đây những điều mà cả bạn và
người khác đều không biết với bạn đấy
tiềm năng chưa được khai phá ô cái này
còn khác nữa
thiếu gì chưa biết mình thiếu gì đấy này
biết người khác không biết gì về mình Ui
Đọc câu này lú quá bảo sao không nhớ
thể chia sẻ Ok bào sao tôi không để ý
cái này
năm nhất năm2 đại học Tôi đã thấy nó hot
rồi đến bây giờ tôi vẫn chưa học Thằng
bạn tôi năm nhất 52 cái hồi hồi mà nó
mới ra luôn ý đấy Kiểu kiểu dạng là
thằng đấy nó mình nó mình nói trong lớp
học câu Lang x Bọn tôi cười nó kiểu Tại
sao mày không học p Đi kiểu ở trường dạy
p dậ nh mày học cốp lang không biết
không biết bây giờ nó đang là Xếp ở đâu
rồi đúng R cười người sớm Bởi vì hồi đấy
là kiểu dạng như nh câu Lang chưa phổ
biến nên là việc học tài liệu hay mọi
thứ rất là khó kiểu thì mọi người cười
nó là bởi vì nó thích chọn con đường khó
nó đi ý ông hiểu không đấy Kiểu
rồi mà tôi dạy tôi chỉ dám dạy những cái
thứ mà tôi giỏi ví dụ như là cái SQL tôi
còn tự tin một phần thì tôi kiểu cũng
thực chiến nó nhiều kiến thức về lý
thuyết có thể không sâu rộng nhưng mà
mình thực chiến nó nhiều để mình còn đấy
ví dụ Giả sử có ai nói mình K đạn bắt bẻ
chứ kì à không ai bắt bẻ mình mình CN
cãi lại chứ bâ giờ giả sử không kiến
thước gì nói ché gió cái bị bị lòe bị
phủ đầu vài cái là mình không dám đi dậy
nữa không đi dậy Thực ra thì như tôi
thường hay chia sẻ mấy ông là thực ra
kiến thức của tôi cũng chẳng hơn ai kém
rất nhiều thầy cô xong rồi kinh nghiệm
thực tế thì cũng không phải có nhiều lắm
V Đấy tính ra đây là công ty công ty đầu
tiên tôi thực tập thì không nói n đây Cứ
cho là công ty chính thức đầu tiên bởi
vì hồi trước là đi dạy học xong rồi bây
giờ đi thực đi làm luôn ở công ty này và
làm Bây giờ là hơn 3 năm rồi nghĩa là
cũng hơi an phận một tí nên thành ra anh
đấy cũng bảo V tôi là đáng lẽ cũng nên
đi va chạm một vài công ty gọi là anh ấy
có dùng từ đó là như này em rất là may
đặc biệt là may hơn cả anh đó
là vừa ra vừa ra bước ra đời cái kiểu
Vấp ngay vào công ty setup kiểu các thứ
ngon lành đấy Xong rồi Công việc ổn định
và có cơ hội phát triển mọi thứ Vân Vân
Vân Vân đấy nhưng cũng rất là giờ bởi
vì em cũng ở đây quá lâu rồi và đến thời
điểm hiện tại nó vẫn đang ngon nên thành
ra em vẫn đang vẫn đang làm ở đây và tôi
còn định làm ở đây đế khi nghỉ h gọi là
nghỉ cũng tương đối nghỉ lập trình kiểu
đến khi là đi dậy hẳn về sau mà Đấy
nghĩa là thành ra là kiểu mình ít va
chạm với những công ty
khác đã từng làm công ty tập đoàn lớn
khác nào đâu đấy vân vân sống chết công
ty à dùng từ đấy cũng đúng Vì kiểu ở đây
Nói chung là mọi người mọi thứ cơ hội
Mọi thứ rất là ổn
ấy an toàn quá Ừ hồi trước là tôi đã
từng nói mấy ông về việc là tôi tôi đã
thoát ra khỏi cái an toàn là tôi nghỉ
dậy rồi hồi hồi đấy là
tôi hồi đấy 22 23 tuổi đã được đi dậy Ui
làm giảng viên nghe oai đúng không 23
tuổi lên làm trưởng bộ môn rất oa luôn
lương thì hơn
30 bởi vì hồi đấy là dậy học bơ mà dậy
từ 8:00 sáng đến 9:30 tối dậy cả từ thứ
hai đến thứ bảy đấy ngày nào cũng thế
kiểu dãy vãi trưởng lương rất là cao
Tiên Dung dịch vân vân xong rồi địa vị
thì ổn
Đấy xong rồi thực ra là cái này còn nói
riêng mấy ông nữa đó là con gái thì
thích con gái
thích có kiểu dễ dễ cảm nắng với người
mà mình ngưỡng mộ thân tượng thường là
các kiểu người bao gồm việc là người mà
Đấy ngưỡng mộ vào việc các thầy cũng
cũng ngưỡng mộ mà các thầy trẻ có vẻ là
cũng ổn đấy chứ đúng không sự thật là
như
không vô hình cho mắt con gái nữa h Hồi
trước thì tôi vẫn nghĩ tôi là ler kiểu
vơ mà wibu xong rồi voer Ui các thứ xong
rồi May mà có tí địa vị gì cái coi như
là ít ra không vô hình trong mắt các bạn
nữ
nhỉ Hôm nay tâm sự nhiều phết nói chuyện
nhiều
thời buổi le of everywhere thế này thì
nên cẩn thận Ừ tôi tôi cũng lo ấy chứ
Nhưng mà thực ra cũng nửa lo nửa không
Đấy đấy là một trong những cái đó là bây
giờ giả sử tôi mà đúng mà nhảy sang công
ty khác bây giờ là cũng may rồi rất là
nhiều đấy
lành lành ít giữ nhiều à Nghĩa là nghĩa
chỉ là bây giờ sang công ty khác Ừ thì
tôi khẳng định tôi khẳng định nhá đó Có
thể tôi có thể điêu lương tốt hơn vì
tính ra công ty tôi đang làm công ty
stup thì lương nó trả vẫn chỉ mức tương
đối
đấy Nên là sang công ty khác hoàn toàn
thể đi Lương hấp dẫn hơn nhưng mà nhưng
mà nó cũng sẽ cạnh tranh hơn và và đấy
như ông bảo nhiều công ty giờ cũng x Hải
thử thứ nhiều hôm nay hôm nay chính tôi
cũng vừa mời anh mon Minh mon men kia về
về công ty tôi để phóng vấn để để kiểu
dạng là xem xem kiểu phù hợp về công ty
tôi không mà đấy thì anh anh leader bên
tôi nói đùa là bình thường các công ty
khác thì đang kiểu đang đấy đang la h
đang kiểu đuổi bớt Nhân sự thì công ty
mình vẫn đuổi vẫn tuyển thêm đấy nghe
oai chứng tỏ công ty vẫn đang rất là
phát triển đang rất là ổn nên là cần
thêm người
đấy công ty khác mà bây giờ kiểu cũng
đang sai Hải bớt dần mà đúng không ạ
công ty tôi Thực ra là anh em đp cũng
không nhiều lắm đâu nên là nên là tôi
cảm thấy là ít nhất thời điểm hiện tại
tôi vẫn đang Khá an toàn với cái chiếc
ghế của mình nhưng mà đương nhiên là
mình không nên ngủ quên trong chiến
thắng thì vẫn vẫn nên kiểu vẫn nên kiểu
luôn tro dồi trên kiến thức và vân vân
đúng không ạ may là tôi vẫn có khả năng
cầu tiến và vẫn vẫn kiểu Gồng Gồng r làm
hết sức rồi Làm cũng vượt chỉ tiêu chứ
Thế nên là vừa rồi thực ra mấy không
theo dõi à đâu Tôi có đăng cả trên
Facebook đấy tôi đăng Facebook là tôi
vẫn được làm nhân viên của năm mà vì tôi
khá là nhiệt tình đấy kểu thế May mà
nhiệt tình ở đây là chưa đi kèm với phá
hoại vẫn ổn
ổn ở một công ty nào đó kiểu rất là lâu
dài rồi bây giờ đi phỏng vấn ra ngoài
nên là cũng bị sốc các thứ thứ Nên là
anh Minh mom đấy Hôm đấy chia sẻ tôi
nhiều vậy bao gồm cả việc là anh ấy bảo
là thỉnh thoảng em phải nên đi phỏng vấn
ở ngoài thực ra cái này tôi khuyên lại
mấy ông bởi vì tính Tôi thích chia sẻ
Tôi thích khuyên lại cả những điều rất
là thật lòng nhưng mà nó cũng sẽ rất là
tế nhị bởi vì
May bây giờ chưa nổi chứ bây giờ nổi rồi
mà công ty khác mà nghe tôi nói cái này
chắc giết tôi mất Đó là kiểu mấy ông
thỉnh thoảng vẫn nên đi phỏng vấn ở
ngoài để biết được thị trường bên ngoài
đang như thế nào Vân Vân Vân Đấy biết
được các kỹ năng cần ở cái trình độ Mình
thậm chí biết mức lương ở bên ngoài so
với cái trình độ mình đáng e phải bao
nhiêu vân vân đấy đương nhiên là nói thế
đi phòng vấn ngoài chưa chắc là để mấy
ông nghỉ việc nhảy sang bên khác nên là
thành ra là các công ty khác mà biết
việc là kiểu mấy ông khỏng vấn cho vui
thì chắc là m giết tôi mất nhưng mà
nhưng mà sự thật là như thế nghĩa là mấy
ông cũng phải đi khảo sát các thử
biết gì thì mình bắt đầu từ đâu
vừa đi em Sao khuyên thế
Ờ tôi thì nhưng mà Đúng là sin 54 thì
vẫn còn đang chơi vơi vân vân vân thậm
chí là ra trường rồi vẫn có nhiều người
chơi vơi tôi thì tôi không khuyên các
bạn theo kiểu là đa cấp là theo
kiểu theo theo kiểu là là lật trình hay
lắm kiểu vân vân vân kiểu mọi thứ cơ hội
hấp dẫn lắm kiểu nhảy sang vào đi dễ lắm
Không nhưng
mà nhưng mà thường là tôi vẫn hướng dẫn
mấy ông đó là mấy ông đó là mấy ông đã
theo cái gì mấy ông phải theo
nó phải thử hết sức với nó đã mấy ông có
đang mông lung mấy ông có đang chơi vơi
thì mấy ông phải xem mấy video này này
mấy video này ho mấy video hôm trước tôi
có đăng ấy là gọi là cũng hơi phũ một tí
là chửi thẳng mặt ấy thì để mấy ông tỉnh
ra mấy ông học hành các thứ tôi nói
thẳng thì đương nhiên là mỗi người mỗi
cảnh thôi nhưng mà thật sự là bây giờ
đúng là việc quan trọng nhất
mình cái thời gian mà trên trường ấy thì
quan trọng nhất vẫn là đi học đúng không
ạ đặc biệt đặc biệt là mấy ông ở đây
thôi chứ mấy ông mà kiểu dạng còn đ đi
du học ấ tôi từng quen nhiều người đi vô
học người ta đi vô học thì đương nhiên
là người ta cũng kiểu muốn tranh thủ
kiếm gì đó Ngoài việc kiếm tiền gửi về
cho gia đình thậm chí là kiếm tiền để mà
chu cấp cho cuộc sống ở bên đấy thành ra
là kiểu người ta bận làm cái khác còn
hơn cả việc học ấy th nĩ là kiểu mang
tiếng là đi vô học code để kiểu học được
thực ra lại dành quá nhiều thời gian cho
việc làm thêm hay vân vân hơn ấy thành
ra là n ảnh
hưởng nếu có thể là mấy ông nên làm mọi
thứ t để tốt nhất cho việc học của mấy
ông và để tốt nhất cho cái ngành của mấy
ông
Ờ em 50 50 Nên là giờ khó chọn á Đấy
thức C là thời của tôi tôi biết được là
tôi chẳng còn cái đường lui gì cả tôi
chỉ có một một đâm thẳng đường mà đi
Thôi không đi nữa thì cặp đất mà ăn và
tôi quen rất nhiều người như thế thành
ra là kiểu bướt gần như là bước con
đường duy nhất với bước đường cùng như
thế Mình cắm đầu vào đi thì mình còn đi
được chứ Các bạn bâ có liề nhiều lựa
chọn các bạn cũng Cuộc sống cũng gọi là
tôi cảm thấy cảm thấy là nó cũng gọi là
có nhiều lựa chọn hơn thành ra là kiểu
nó bị phân tâm như thế cho mình một lựa
chọn thôi cắm đầu mà đi thôi đi đi đến
thực sự là kiểu về sao mình cảm thấy nó
đường cụt rồi mình bắt đầu mới rẽ chứ
đừng
có đi x rồi một là dậm chân tại chỗ như
thế hai là đi rồi cứ ngi ngoái sang
đường bên kia xem đường bên kia có tắc
hay không đi sang đường bên kia cứ đảo
đảo như thế thì mình không đi xa được
đúng không ạ mình không Mình không tập
trung vào một đường đi
số đa số bây giờ bị thế đó là kiểu không
phải nói về cái con chọn con đường nữa
Mà đa số là nói chung là tôi cảm thấy
tôi không hơn người ta về giỏi trình độ
mọi thứ đấy tôi thừa nhận tôi kém các
thứ nhưng tôi
thấy tôi thắng được chính bản thân tôi
nên là tôi mới có thể ngồi đây để nói
được mấy ông đấy bởi vì nhiều người đang
nghe tôi giờ có thể đang không chiến
thắng chính bản thân mình là không là ý
chí không đủ mạnh hay Vân Vân rất nhiều
yếu tố họ bị cuộc đời đánh cục rồi nên
là họ nản họ tự bỏ
đấy Tôi thì lạc quan là tôi đã từng có
rất nhiều lúc ngã rẽ là theo kiểu tôi
buông bỏ tất cả nghĩ ra bây giờ tôi chưa
buông nên thành ra tôi vẫn mạnh mồm được
vẫn gáy được đấy nhiều người thì buông
rồi Nhiều người kiểu cứ thả số phận các
thứ các thứ nên thành ra là mới bị chơi
vơ như
thế đúng không
ạ
biết về tí mạng rồi bạn vẫn muốn lập
trình này theo thc ra có rất nhiều cái
công việc nó ở giữa giống như dep hay
các thứ hoàn toàn vẫn ổn không Đừng có
nghĩ việc là mình chỉ cần chọn một mà
mình bị thừa cái kiến thức kiểu bị lão
phí kiến thức trước không Công nghệ
thông tin này nó vẫn có cái sự mâu à sự
sâu chuỗi giữa hai thằng với nhau rất có
nhiều học lập trình là để dàn tư duy
thôi nế Thực ra là các bạn hoàn toàn học
công nghệ thông tin nói chung này các
bạn có rất nhiều nghề Và thậm chí có rất
nhiều nghề gọi là mãi vì sau bạn mới
biết tên cơ Nói chung là nó kiểu nó là
đan xen rất nhiều
cái nói chung là các bạn Đây bây giờ để
mà nói các bạn liệt kê được có bao nhiêu
công việc liên quan công nghệ tin Các
bạn có biết được hết không không bạn
thân tôi Tôi không biết được hết rồi
Nhiều nề
lắm kiểu nên cứ phải học cho rồi Đã xong
rồi về sau thậm chí là về xong mình
không biết được công việc gì mình cứ ứng
tuyển công ty công ty tự cho mình vào
công việc phù hợp thôi phù hợp năng lực
của mình Miễn là mình có học mà có năng
lực Còn Đây là kiểu ông không Ông cảm
thấy ông không chọn được cái gì ông
không học luôn
thì thì chẳng công ty vào tuyển cả đúng
không Ông có học ông có kiến thức ông có
năng lực kiểu gì công ty sẽ nhét ông vào
được cái vị trí gì đó phù hợp đúng không
ạ Thế
đường đi đã và ông phải đi đấy giống như
kiểu học rộng hay học sâu này ông cảm
thấy ông học rộng được ông học rộng còn
ông phù hợp việc là ngồi tro dồi tài
liệu thì ông học sâu h sâu hẳn cái gì đó
cứ phải học đã à học đủ trên thường xong
rồi học thêm kiến thức mà mình cũng
thích mà mình mình thấy thực tế cũng cần
đấy Mình học thêm vào các thứ rồi kiểu
gì cũng sẽ có việc cho mấy ông tin tôi
đi chứ còn tin tôi nói hoặc là tin bản
thân mình tin một cái gì đó phải có niềm
tin
nữa chứ mình mà học mà mình mình học mà
mình nghi ngờ là Nó chẳng ra được đến
đâu đâu các thứ thứ thì cũng dở theo tôi
Tôi sống cuộ sống tôi có niềm tin mãnh
liệt á tôi tự tin
mà em học khoa học máy tính xong học
theo ngành hướng ngành robot mà hơi
nhọc các bạn vẫn trong thời gian đi học
thì đương nhiên các bạn vẫn còn cảm thấy
kiểu áp lực xong rồi mơ hồ việc học đi
làm về sau thì à Nó còn áp lực hơn rất
nhiều và lúc đấy th các bạn cảm thấy là
hồi thấy việc học còn thoải mái
chán nhưng mà nhưng mà tôi cũng thường
hay khoe đó là nói thế nhưng mà tôi để
mà tôi Giả sử để quay lại quá khứ ý để
chọn công việc này hay là kiểu để vân
vân vân thì tôi không muốn qu hệ quá khứ
đâu Tôi cảm thấy là tôi rất là hài lòng
thời điểm hiện tại rồi mang tiếng công
việc rất là cũng không phải là thoải
nhàn không có Nhàn cũng rất là vất Nhưng
mà mình được thoải mái hơn trong những
cái
khác
đấy được tự do trong rất nhiều cái khác
nên là tôi thấy nó đánh đổi rất là xứng
đáng đấy Ô bây giờ cũng ngồi tâm sự tận
hai tiếng rồi Chắc là để tôi tôi để danh
sách này ở đây và form câu hỏi ở có link
câu hỏi ở kia Ờ có gì mấy ông cần tâm sự
chia sẻ thì có thể bấm vào link câu hỏi
để mà tâm sự rồi hỏi hoặc là inbox riêng
nha đây hoặc là đấy nhắn trong discord
thì tôi vẫn thường xuyên theo dõi trả
lời nha Ok hôm n hai tiếng rồi Chào mấy
ông nhé Bye